okay hey call 9-1-1 no don't call my one
though fine
no they're good just about a vehicle
Sully Sully official trailer number one
this is Braden
this is Greg Greg Sully is a movie
directed by Clinton Eastwood er stars
Thomas the Hanks a nurse it's based on a
true story about somebody who did
something amazing and I heard most of
this movie is shot with IMAX cameras
yeah and I hear it's a drama which is
really interesting that's all thanks oh
not so much again okay like fill with
spectacle and stuff but like a whole
drama it's gonna be immersive biopic
experience let's see if it's worth even
checking out people
really oh one more
no one said you were going to lose both
engines at a lower altitude than in
Egypt in history this was dual engine
loss at 2,800 feet followed by an
immediate water landing but 155 souls on
board
no one has ever trained for an incident
like that
our job is to investigate how playing ed
up in the Hudson River her hat card
forced water simulations showed that you
could make it back to the airport not
possible I felt it go
my aircraft did the best I could
of course you did just have to everyone
people call me or hear but I don't feel
like it's already all this attention the
left enjoys last drink Atma Solberg and
he had any troubles at home
geez
you for one of them
odd years in the air Wow
I know it was great look at that it
looks fantastic right that's totally my
kind of movie I could tell by how you
just look but that is your kind of movie
- that's some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] I feel
Clint Eastwood's lighting in movies
tends to be really dark and it was
excessively used in the biopic by Jay
Edgar I like that it doesn't look so
shadowy and dark the whole time you know
kind of look like a snow burger or
Robert Zemeckis film at some points you
know and Tom Hanks looks like he's doing
an amazing job like oh maybe you're
getting old Braden [ __ ] dude you're
getting older you're taking it out on
these [ __ ] legends Tom Hanks is a
legend I know he's a legend he's woody
big you've got mail The Da Vinci Code I
get it it's Tom Hanks he did um was that
one word like I'm the captain now that
wasn't him who said that no he's in the
movie I feel it was a captain yeah this
looks like a different kind of biopic
because it seems like we are getting to
explore this character it does surround
him at a very specific offender man
really such that's such this hear what
he has to go through about all that [ __ ]
man
like what the [ __ ] he saves the plane
and gets blamed for [ __ ] [ __ ] he
gets blamed for [ __ ] man like he
clearly had experience flying the
airplane experience though does seem
horrifying you know okay like to me what
comes to mind is the movie Passion of
the Christ
okay hear me out here for a second
Bradon Passion of the Christ really put
you in the experience of when Jesus was
being tortured you know in this horrible
experience that he had to do in order to
save the rest of humanity
I think the IMAX
dance is gonna be [ __ ] scary because
that doesn't look like cool CGI
spectacle that looks like this is a
scary situation there's like guys
[ __ ] text to whoever yeah just likes
cuz you're in the seats in the theater
like am I on the [ __ ] plane like is
this happening when everyone ducked down
and stuff and I was like you never said
the fact that they did that show this
sense of realism yeah even though Tom
Hanks kind of looks like a well-groomed
Santa Claus I still think that he pulls
off the look well and Aaron Eckhart
I don't know Aaron Eckhart's playing me
he just looks like a porn star yeah no
that's definitely an eighties mustache
porn I take it up the butt and put it in
butts I always need a hanging out with
you outside of class would be fun thanks
man I'm glad having a blast really oh
yeah totally
no yeah the blast is totally being
blasted over when I watch this movie and
I'm going to watch this movie when I
hear a film is shot with IMAX cameras I
always always watch them even if I watch
the movie on a 2d spring and I don't
like it I will go watch it again on IMAX
if they shot some of that with IMAX
cameras I really feel like it's gonna
put you into the the mood and turmoil I
feel sorry for this guy man he's like
worked his whole life as a pilot and
then in 208 seconds he's gonna get
judged this could be another Academy
award-winning performance for Tom Hanks
hey I smell
I totally smell Oscar here smelling it
oh yeah that's the season baby yes
biography Eastwood he does good movies
I'd say I saw like 80 to 85% at the time
well and that was in that 80 to 85
percent those movies
are really good you know what you have
to fall to know what it's like to stand
well on that comedy note subscribe you
better [ __ ] do it
Nana Mimi
it's like Rio a Braden Adam II and
what's your snapchat Braden f23 same
with us as much with it okay cool
now listen we're gonna head out now work
done Braden it is the 5:40 p.m. hour I
think now is a good time for you to
start hopping on that freeway and get
the [ __ ] back home well do I know
without traffic it can be up to an hour
however easily this time you're looking
at a smooth relaxing drive about an hour
and a half two hours just like that
[ __ ] nice bod can you buy going down
your throat it's gonna be smooth as
compared to [ __ ] [ __ ] absolutely
or something worse if you buy it in a
plastic ball if you buy it in a plastic
bottle at the supermarket you're like
it's some cheap [ __ ] [ __ ] oh do you
get like Grey Goose well what's that
[ __ ] with a deer on it
that's how smooth my ride this videos
done